welcome to this video playing dragon 70
dragon 70 at hydrating who is that guy
was that a medic said cast Kashian I
cannot probably don't pronounce that
correctly yep good GM from the US
interesting play a very very sharp
player Knight f6 he will probably go d 4
which is not really good but I don't
know it well so I'm going with a
conservative approach here okay it
probably will lead to the usual stuff in
them well it's interesting that he buys
gh3 that is considered to be quite quite
risky for white when i have not
cancelled yet surprised that he is
allowing that it's a pretty well-known
thing and he saw i mean it's a chess
teacher usually good at theoretical
thing so kind of surprised that he
allows that maybe he's not so sure about
it but I really think that black has an
excellent a check here now I'm just
getting the g file open and probably can
Castle queenside quite quickly there are
ideas like we have three here but i can
go Queenie seven and only then t1 g for
Queen a3 is so yeah that's interesting
and take with the pawn or take with the
with the rook I take where the rook the
G file will be open it's a more dynamic
option and with the pawn is not that bad
I mean any night where three is going to
be kicked and if he goes g3 yeah I'm
going to threaten that the g3 move why
isn't that really a threat I mean it is
a threat in some way but
thing about it what is this idea just
should be three probably
and g4s probably a bit strong that
medicine he plays Bishop e3 and I take
you probably will take with the f pawn
so maybe maybe this move just yeah
making this whole structure a little bit
more solid covering f7 so if i take it
or he might take with the night actually
interesting yeah okay I think he
defended that well with this g5 idea
Knight takes looks very logical him
actually to look at the light squares
and maybe 95 as a possible option okay i
think i played this guy before he has an
entirely different idea about the game
and then i have i never guess any move
it sir sometimes you just have this kind
of totally opposing idea what what you
should do in a cake and what not ok
Queen f3 is is an interesting move hey I
guess one right so um 97 probably then
Catholic no I wonder if naija force an
idea now probably SS porn if I get g4
know is never playing it will almost
never move that I expect
yeah okay d 5 is this is an interesting
idea of course just just a fork what
about Knight to f6 status Knight f6 g5
night XD 4mm start working ok can check
on f6 at least 95 is a bit bit of a
problem here as my bishop also has no
squares and I don't want to take on c4
that looks entirely wrong maybe I can
still play it and it's not what i wanted
to do really not taking you folks I have
four you gave one now can check I Scott
look at five either here or next move
that's a problem I should have gone
maybe I should have gone to d7 here
yah gave five that's a that's annoying
check okay so any choice Jim probably
meant probably not on
I promise he's got is more active and
the the biggest issue is that the g1s
began my king is weak that's two things
two things the same time I can go queen
age for even look at this man that this
head looks really bad
so such helping in some way I don't know
if I go bad takes takes Knight takes
Knight f6 yeah the night end game might
be losing directly if I go Knight to f6
here alright still I go to g3 time
morning it's not great now it's just a
bad position oh it's really interesting
to learn I really think that this
opening line that you played is just bad
how did I do wrong into a really
interesting question ok I have we can be
six why am i doing that anyway let's see
check still have a look at the d4 pawn
maybe it's not so easy to win with pawns
on c4 energy for he cannot easily can go
be 3m and come around with the King not
a five-night exif wats it's okay
not quite clear yet to me how he wins it
the corn it's not worth much on III
maybe I'm okay gain drown it is a
repetition I didn't even see that yeah
funny yo let me check that maybe maybe I
did something I don't know okay I can
take with the rook maybe that's that's
the real issue maybe this is better I
don't know rook takes is an interesting
move it just looks a bit wrong to put it
there but the g fat is open so something
like that is interesting i have this
this very very big thread i can do this
later queener three a human this is
interesting i'm not sure i've really
root shakes if that is any better it's
um it's an interesting position I don't
know it looks interesting I mean pawn
takes cannot cannot be really bad so
okay maybe maybe I should really go g4
here I was thinking you can do this but
I are the computer gives this move that
that's strong that's strong and be
easily missed the problem is if you know
does that i have g 3 which is really a
bad bad bad idea for wide so g form how
interesting maybe has to go g3 yep
writing
maybe this sad g43 and now i can i come
from here like 27 that that might be it
might be might be better in comparison
but okay I went here when there should
be three I took it and he took with the
f porn yeah I didn't really expect that
move it did seem wrong to me yeah the
engine actually agrees but I didn't play
right that that's engine gives this move
okay how about this Bhatia why didn't I
do that actually preventing this and
threatening g3 white has to do this and
now rook age 8 and rook h3 is coming
that's very good for black and a
computer gives black a win actually like
a flat-out win okay no I didn't didn't
see that I mean I don't really I mean
didn't see that really didn't think here
right Jack we need satellite looks
normal but Queenie r3 and now charity
form defaults to profess the problem and
gives this which still has this idea and
again black is clearly better
interesting huh Herrick g6 is a move
that looks a bit strange to put that
rook into this kind of dependent
position there on non g6 but yeah he SSD
for IDM that's just like that yeah and
this is probably probably just bad yeah
because of rock f6 now it's a bit that
that's a bit awkward now is 85 idea I
was thinking that this might be might be
an idea but you can take on f6 otherwise
it would be nicer taking in that poem
but he can just take and play d5 and
here I don't really have a great move
the comp gives rook
I've what that's a very strange move
what is that was doing Computers
assessment is equal by the way okay so
here I'm in deep trouble check okay that
that is very good but this is already
winning oops cheeks oops sorry Quinn
back cheeks to check this and now he's
coming here okay yeah I mean I was
certainly certainly lost around here
check this is funny i'm really not so
sure about about the the night end game
maybe that that really wasn't wasn't the
best that's a mistake i think yeah if he
allows see for jamie has to to do it
like that and then try to yeah but how
does he actually even know it's not easy
really in every time he goes night at 5a
take that and what is what exactly is
his idea now if I'm just staying I just
I just stay put how is he going to do it
like this and this I mean I just stay I
just don't react to it like b6 and just
keep the position as is huh maybe I'm
okay I don't know after all that's the
pawn I mean that's not the greatest porn
ever check
yeah yeah yeah I'm definitely okay yeah
interesting game in any case thanks for
watching